the clark county school district updates
the transition plan to the hybrid
instructional model
80s now reporter kristen drummond has
the very latest on the guide
ccsd posted the now 235 page guide on
the website
slightly more reading material than the
original document released in november
but
it offers updated information about
school protocols cleaning operations and
the overall transition ccsd is preparing
to welcome back only pre-kindergarten to
third grade students in buildings on
march
1st all staff and students must wear a
face covering
but there are a few exceptions when it
can be removed
a few pages outline the type of personal
protective equipment or
ppe required for employees depending on
the job
the document also highlights teacher
assignments and either cohort a
b or c cohort c is full-time distance
education
and the other two incorporate in-person
and online learning
towards the end of the guide the
district offers sample schedules to see
what a typical day looks like for not
only elementary but middle school
and high schools the document offers
direction for secondary schools but
it remains unknown when hybrid learning
will start for those grade levels
the release of the updated guide comes
five days after lower elementary school
students had to choose between
continuing distance education or
starting hybrid learning
the timing frustrating some families who
wanted this information ahead of time
in the newsroom kristen drummond 8 news
now